the status quo has propped up white
supremacy and patriarchy and Injustice
what did he say there
um well he said nothing at all that was
nothing that was a whole rhetorical
parade of nothing and this to me is the
real tragedy it's not the worst thing to
have a culture you know a culture at war
between two factions who are deeply
opposed to one another it's not the best
thing it's not a good thing you prefer
not to have that situation but it's not
the worst thing I think the worst thing
is this
where we're at War
but we're at war with people who speak
exclusively in cliches
people who are you know um
absolutely phony who are as human and
authentic as chat Bots
this is a culture War but a very
decadent one